[Music]
answer will provides you with one of the
easiest ways to automate your
application and i-tree infrastructure on
that note hi guys welcome to this
complete absolute tutorial by simply
learned in this video we'll be covering
some of the most important concepts
relating to the DevOps tool ansible
we take you through how you can install
ansible and how you can use the tool to
automate your courses first we have one
journey to tell us how to install
ansible on your system a very warm
welcome to all of yours and anjali from
simply learn and today I will be showing
you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
an table a small team of system
administrators can write simple codes in
G Amin and these codes are deployed on
to the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
States so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my Oracle VM VirtualBox manager I'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's the server system or
the master system so let's begin at a
server system so this is my master
system guys so the first thing we do is
we download our ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike chef or puppet
ansible is a push type of configuration
management tool so what this means is
that the entire control here lies with
your master or your server system this
is where you write your configuration
files and these are also responsible for
pushing these code figuration files onto
your node or client system as and when
required
crepes are ansible tool is installed now
we need to open a ansible horse file and
there will specify the details of our
node offline machine
so this sir ansible horse pile as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group named web servers under
which we have the IP addresses or
certain hostname so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this grooc basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the IP address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the IP address 192
point 168 point two point eleven
once you have tied in your IP address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for a client machine so all
communications between the server or the
master system and the client or the node
system takes place through SSH SSH
basically provides a secure channel for
the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the routes password and that's
it we are done
so now we save this file and go back to
our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write a
playbook
the playbook is the technical term used
for all the configuration files that we
write in ansible now play books are
written in Jamel yea Milles extremely
simple to both write and understand it's
in fact very close to English
so now we'll write a playbook the
playbook or any kodi neeya mel first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook so
name and I'm going to name my playbook
sample book we next need to specify our
host systems which is basically the
systems at which the configuration file
or the PlayBook in our case will be
executed
so we'll be executing this a decline
machines mentioned under the group
ansible servers so we had just one line
machine under it we will still mention
the group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
line machine which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation next we need to
specify our TAS so these are basically
the actions that the playbook will be
performing so you would have noticed
everything so far is aligned that is
named host remote user become and tasks
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under tasks will be
shifted slightly towards these right
although yeah Mel is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing so my first task is
install httpd which is basically a
Apache server so now my commands yam and
this will be installing the httpd
package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task would be running our
Apache service so named run httpd and
the action which is service
we'll be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd and state must be started now
we come to a third task so here we
create a very simple web page that will
be hosted so create content is the name
of a task and the content that we are
creating here will basically be copied
to a node system at a particular file
location that will provide a content
will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our HTML files and that's it we are done
writing our playbook just save this and
go back to your terminal
before we execute the PlayBook or push
the PlayBook on to our north system
let's check these syntax of our playbook
so the command for doing so is
and if everything's fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
PlayBook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
unknown or the climb machine and that's
the syntax for doing so
now as your PlayBook is being sent over
to the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
ok because this does not need to be
changed on next task was running httpd
now although our system had the Apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were ok now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that we check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to a node system and we'll just
go to a browser so if a playbook has
been executed here what should happen is
that the httpd service must be in the
running state and the web page that we
created should be hosted so let's just
type localhost and great everything's
working fine so our web page is
displayed here so we come to an end for
our installation and configuration video
for the configuration management tool
ansible
if you have any doubts please post them
in the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible thanks Angie now we have
Matthew and Anjali take us through how
to work with ansible ansible today as
one of the key tools that you would have
within your dev ops environment
so the things that we going to go
through today is we're gonna cover why
you would want to use a product like
ansible
what ansible really is and how it's all
value to you in your organization
the difference is between ansible and
other products that
similar to it on the market and what
make sensible a compelling product and I
want to dig into the architecture
financeable going to look at how you
would create a playbook how you'd manage
your inventory of your server
environments and then what is the actual
workings of answer Bob a little extra
we're going to also throw in ansible
Tower one of the secret source solutions
that you can use for improving the speed
and performance of how you create your
ansible environments and finally we're
going to go through a use case by
looking at HootSuite social media
management company and how they use
ansible to really improve the efficiency
within their organizations so let's jump
into this so the big question is why
ansible so you have to think of ansible
as another tool that you have within
your DevOps environment for helping
manage the service and this definitely
falls on the operations side of the dev
ops equation so if we look here we have
a picture of Sam and like yourselves Sam
is a system administrator and he is
responsible for maintaining the
infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the services that he may have that he
has to maintain could be web servers
running Apache they could be database
servers running my sequel and if you
only have a few servers then that's
fairly easy to maintain I mean if you
have three web servers and two database
servers and let's face it when we all
love just to have one or two servers to
manage it would be really easy to
maintain the trick however is as we
start increasing the number of servers
and this is a reality of the
environments that we live and operate in
it becomes increasingly difficult to
create consistent setup of different
infrastructures such as web servers and
databases for the simple reason that
we're all human as if we had to update
and maintain all of those servers by
hand there's a good chance that we would
not set up each server identically now
this is where a sport really comes to
the rescue and helps you become an
efficient operations team ansible like
other system solutions such as a chef
and puppet uses code that you can write
into
bribe the installation and set up all of
your servers so you can actually repeat
it and deploy those servers consistently
into multiple areas so now you don't
have to have one person redoing Andry
following setup procedures
you just write one script and then each
script can be executed and have a
consistent environment so we've gone
through why you'd want to use Hanceville
let's step through what a spool really
is so you know this is all great but you
know how do we actually use these tools
in our environment so ansible hat is a
tool that really allows you to create
and control three key areas that you
would have within your operations
environment first of all there's IT
automation so you can actually write
instructions that automate the IT setup
that you would typically do manually in
the past the second is the configuration
and having consistent configuration
imagine setting up hundreds of Apache
servers and being able to guarantee with
precision that each of those Apache
servers is set up identically and then
finally you want to be able to automate
the deployment so that as you scale up
your server environment you can just
push out instructions that can deploy
automatically different servers the
bottom line is you want to be able to
speed up and make your operations team
more efficient so let's talk a little
bit about poor configuration and how it
works with ansible so there are two
different ways of being able to set up
different environments for server farms
one is to have a key server that has all
the instructions on and then on each of
the servers that connect to that main
master server you would have a piece of
software known as a client installed on
each of those servers that would
communicate to the main master server
and then we periodically either update
or change the configuration of the slave
server this is known as a polka
figuration an alternative is a push
configuration and the perfect
configuration is slightly different the
main difference
is as with a pull configuration you have
a master server where you actually put
up the instructions but unlike the pull
configuration where you have a client
installed on each of the services with a
push configuration you actually have no
client installed on the remote servers
you simply are pushing out the
configuration to those servers and
forcing a restructure or a fresh clean
installation in that environment so
ansible is one of those second arounds
where it's a push configuration server
and this contrasts with other popular
products like chef and puppet which
having master slave architecture with a
master server connecting with a client
on a remote slave environment where you
would then be pushing out the update
with as well you're pushing out the
service and the structure of the server
to remote hardware and you are just
putting it onto the hardware irrelevant
of the structure that's out there and
there are some significant advantages
that you have in that in that you're not
having to have the extra overhead weight
of a client installed on those remote
servers having to constantly communicate
back to the master environment so let's
step through the architecture that you
would have for an answer bowl
environment so when you're setting up an
ant ansible environment the first thing
you want to do is have a local machine
and the local machine is where you're
going to have all of your instruction
and really the power of the control that
you'd be pushing out to the remote
server so the local machine is where
you're gonna be starting and doing all
of your work connected from the local
machine are all the different nodes
pushing out the different configurations
that you would set up on the local
machine the configurations that you
would write and you would write those in
code out within a module so you do this
on your local machine for creating these
modules and each of these modules is
actually consistent playbooks the local
machine also has a second job and that
job is to manage the inventory of the
nodes that you have in your environment
the local machine is able to connect to
each of the different nodes that you
would have in your hardware network
through SSH clients or a secure client
let's dig into some of the different
elements within that architecture we're
going to take a first look at play books
that you would write and create for the
ansible environments so the core of an
s' wall is the playbook this is where
you create the instructions that you
write to define the architecture of your
hardware so the PlayBook is really just
a set of instructions that configure the
different nodes that you have and each
of those set of instructions is written
in a language called Yama and this is a
standard language used for configuration
server environments did you know that
Yama actually stands for a camel ain't
markup language that's just a little
tidbit to hide behind your ear so let's
have a look or one of these play boats
it looks like and here we have a sample
Yama script that we've written so you
start off your Yama script with three
dashes and that indicates the start of a
script and then the script itself is
actually consistent of two distinct
plays at the top we have play 1 and
below that we have played 2 within each
of those plays we define which nodes are
we targeting so here we have a web
server in the top play and in the second
plate we have a database server that
were targeting and then within each of
those server environments we have the
specific tasks that we're looking to
execute so let's step through some of
these tasks we have an install pachi
tasks we have a start Apache task and we
have it installed my sequel task and
when we do that we're going to execute a
specific set of instructions and those
instructions can include installing
Apache and then setting the state of the
Apache environments or starting the
Apache environment and setting up and
running the my sequel environment so
this really isn't too complicated and
that's the really good thing about
working with young is it's really
designed to make it easy for you as an
Operations lead to be able to configure
the environments that you want to
consistently create so let's take a step
back though we have two hosts we have
web server and database server why do
these names
come from well this takes us into our
next stage and the second part of
working with ansible which is the
inventory management part of ansible so
the inventory part of ansible is where
we maintain the structure of our network
environment so what we do here is part
of the structure in creating different
nodes is we've had to create two
different nodes here we have a web
server node and a database of server net
and under web server node we actually
have the names that were actually
pointed to specific machines within that
environment so now when we actually
write our scripts all we have to do is
refer to either web server or database
server and the different servers will
have the instructions from the Yama
script executed on them this makes it
really easy for you to be able to just
point to new services without having to
write out complex instructions so let's
have a look at how as what actually
works in real world so the real world
environment will is that you'd have the
answer for software installed on a local
machine and then it connects to
different nodes within your network on
the local machine you'll have your first
your playbook which is the set of
instructions for how to set up the
remote nodes and then to identify how
you're going to connect to those nodes
you'll have an inventory we use secure
SSH connections to each of the servers
so we are encrypting the communication
to those servers we're able to grab some
basic facts on each server so we
understand how we can then push out the
playbook to e7 and configure that server
remotely the end goal is to have an
environment that is consistent so let's
ask you a simple question what are the
major opportunities the ansel has over
chef and pop it really like to hear your
answers in the comments below
pop them in there and we'll get back to
you and really want to hear how you feel
as fall is a stronger product or maybe
you think it's a weaker product as it
compares to other similar products
in the market here's the bonus we're
gonna talk a little bit about ansible
tower so ansible tower is an extra
product that Red Hat created that really
kind of puts the cherry on the top of
the ice cream or is the icing on your
cake ansible by itself is a command-line
tool however as well Tower is a
framework that was designed to access
ansible and through the ansible tower
framework we now have an easy to use GUI
this really makes it easy for non
developers to be able to create the
environment that they want to be able to
manage in their DevOps plan without
having to constantly work with the
command prompt window so instead of
opening up terminal window or a command
window and writing out complex
instructions only in text you can now
use drag and drop and mouse click
actions to be able to create your
appropriate playbooks inventories and
pushes for your nodes alright so we
talked a lot about ansible let's take a
look at a specific company that's using
ansible today and in this example we're
gonna look at HootSuite now HootSuite if
you not already use their products and
they have a great product HootSuite is a
social media management system they are
able to help with you managing your
pushes of social media content across
all of the popular social media
platforms they're able to provide the
analytics they're able to provide the
tools that marketing and sales teams can
use to be able to assess a sentiment
analysis of the messages that are being
pushed out really great tool and very
popular but part of their popularity
drove a specific problem straight to
HootSuite the chance they had at
HootSuite is that they had to constantly
go back and rebuild their server
environment and they couldn't do this
continuously and be consistent there was
no standard documentation and they had
to rely on your memory to be able to do
this consistently imagine how complex
this could get as you're scaling up with
a popular product that
now has tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of users this is where ansible
what came in and really helped the folks
over at HootSuite today the DevOps team
at HootSuite right out play books that
have specific instructions that define
the architecture and structure of their
hardware knows and environments and are
able to do that as a standard product
instead of it being a problem in scaling
up their environment they now are able
to rebuild and create new servers in a
matter of seconds the bottom line is
ansible has been able to provide
HootSuite with IT automation consistent
configuration and free up time from the
operations team so that instead of
managing servers they're able to provide
additional new value to the company a
very warm welcome to all our viewers i'm
anjali from simply learned and today
i'll be taking you through a tutorial on
ansible so ansible
is currently the most trending and
popular configuration management tool
and it's used mostly under the DevOps
approach so what will you be learning
today you'll learn why you should use
ansible what exactly is ansible the
ansible
architecture how ansible works the
beta's benefits of ansible
and finally we will have a demo on the
installation of Apache or the HTTP
package on applying systems
we'll also be hosting a very simple web
page and during this demo I'll also show
you how you can write a very simple
playbook in Yammer and your inventory
file so let's begin why should you use
ansible let's consider a scenario of an
organization where Sam is a system
administrator Sam is responsible for the
company's infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems
this could include your web servers your
database servers the various
repositories and so on so as a system
administrator Sam needs to ensure that
all the systems are running the updated
versions of the software now when you
consider a handful of systems this seems
like a pretty simple task
Sam can simply
from system to system and perform the
configurations required but that is not
the case with an organization is it an
organization has a very large
infrastructure it could have hundreds
and thousands of systems so here is
where sans work gets really difficult
not only does it get tougher Sam has to
move from system to system performing
the same tasks over and over again this
makes Sam board not just that repeating
the same tasks leaves no space for
innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system throw and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible Sam can write simple codes that
are deployed on to all the systems and
configure them to the correct States so
now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
answered ansible
is an IT engine that automates the
following tasks so first we have
orchestration orchestration basically
means bringing together of multiple
applications and ensuring an order in
which these are executed so for example
if you consider a web page that you
require to host this web page stores all
its values that it takes from the user
into a database so the first thing you
must do is ensure that the system has a
database manager and only then do you
host your web page so this kind of an
order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next ansible automate
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired State other tools
that automate configuration management
include puppet and chef and finally
ansible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact and simply
can also ensure that these applications
or the code are deployed at a certain
time or after regular intervals now that
we know what exactly ansible is
let's look at an tubules architecture
ansible has two main components you have
the local machine and you have your node
on the client machine so the local
machine is where the system
administrator sits he or she installs
ansible here and on the other end you
have your node or the client systems so
in case of ansible there's no supporting
software installed here these are just
the systems that are required to be
configured and they are completely
controlled by the local machine at your
local machine you also have a module a
module is a collection of your
configuration files and a case of
ansible these configuration files are
called play books play books are written
in Yael Yael stands for ya man ain't a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your notes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the playbook and the inventory is
written and that will probably make it
clearer so of course a local machine
needs to communicate with a client and
how is this done this is done through
SSH SSH is your secure shell which
basically provides a protected
communication in an unprotected
environment ok so we saw the various
components of ansible now how this
ansible exactly work you have your local
machine on one end this is where you
install ansible if you've gone through
any previous material on ansible you
would have come across the term
agentless often being associated with
this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or plugin being
installed on your clients this means
that you have not agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
ansible is push configuration so since
the local machine has complete control
here it pushes the playbooks on to the
nodes and thus it's called a push
configuration tool
now the playbooks and the inventory are
written at the local machine and the
local machine
next with the notes through the SSH
client this step here is optional but
it's always recommended to do so it's
where the facts are collected so facts
are basically the current state of the
node now all this is collected from the
node and sent to the local machine so
when the playbook is executed the task
mentioned in the playbook is compared
against the current status of the node
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your nodes are
configured to the desired States so as I
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
beta's benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple yet important and provides
automated reporting how does it do all
this let's have a look at that agentless
as I already mentioned before you
require no supporting software or plugin
installed a new node or the client
system so the master has complete
control and automatically this means
that ansible is more efficient because
now we have more space in our client and
node systems for other resources and we
can get ansible up and running real
quick hansip is also flexible so in
infrastructures prone to change very
often and ansible takes no amount of
time to adjust to these changes and
Sybil cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
gamal which is as close to English as
you can possibly get your important
basically means that if you have a
playbook which needs to be run n number
of systems it would have the same effect
on all of these systems without any side
effect and finally we have automated
reporting so in case of ansible your
PlayBook has number of tasks and all
these tasks are named so whenever you
run or execute your playbook
it gives a report on which tasks ran
successfully
which failed which clients were not
reachable and so on
all this information is very crucial
when you are dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
hands-on before we move on to the
hands on let me just brief you through
what exactly will be doing so I'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both sent to
s7 operating systems one would be my
local machine and other my node or the
Kline machine so on my local machine
first I'll install ansible will then
write the inventory and the playbook and
then simply deploy this playbook on the
client machine there's just one thing
that we need to do is that we need to
check if the configuration set we
mentioned in our playbook are made right
so we now begin our demo this my Oracle
VirtualBox here I have my master system
which is the local machine and this is
the client machine so let's have a look
at these two machines this is my client
machine the terminals opened right now
so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install and spill -
why is the command to do so
so this may take some time
you
yeah so ansible installed the next step
we go to a host file so whose file here
is basically the inventory it's where
you will specify all your nodes in our
case we just have one node that's the
path to your host path as you see
everything here is commented so just
type in the group for your client nodes
so I'm going to name it ant built lines
[Music]
and here we need to type the IP address
of a flying machine so my client
machines IP addresses one ninety two
point one sixty eight point two point
one two seven so before you come to this
it's advise that you check the IP
address on your flying machine the
simple command for that is if config now
once you type the IP address put a space
and here we need to mention the username
and the password for our client so I'll
be logging in as the root user so this
is the password and then the user which
is root in my case that's it now you can
save this file just clear the screen
next we move on to a playbook we need to
write the playbook so the extension for
a playbook is why am L which stands for
Yamin and as you can see here I have
already written my playbook but I'll
just explain to you how this is done so
a yam L file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
gamal file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire playbook so I have
named it sample book host is basically
where this would be executed so as we
saw earlier in Iran she I mentioned
clients group name as aunts big clients
so we use the same name here the remote
user is the user you'll be using at your
client so in my case that's route and
become true is basically to indicate
that you need to set your privileges at
root so that's called a privilege
escalation now a playbook consists of
tasks so we have here three tasks the
first tasks have named it to install
httpd so what we are doing here is we
are installing a httpd package which is
basically the Apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is hash TTP D because that's
the service we need to start running and
the state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page so
copy because this is the file that will
be created at the client the content
will be welcome and the destination of
the file will be viable uww HTML index
dot HTML as you know this is like a
default path that we use to store all
our HTML files now as you can see here
there's quite a lot of indentation and
when it comes to yarmilla although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read the indentation is very crucial
so the first dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that
they're siblings so the priority would
be the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yeah mel file the
language is pretty simple
very
readable indentations absolutely
necessary make sure all your spaces are
correctly placed we can now save this
file next thing we need to check if the
syntax of a Yama file is absolutely
light because that's very crucial so the
command to check the syntax of the Yama
file is ansible playbook the name of
your playbook syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is sample
dot yml which is the name of your
PlayBook
so our playbook is ready to be executed
the command to execute the playbook is
ansible playbook and the name of your
PlayBook
so playbooks executed as you can see her
gathering facts that's where all the
facts of the note that the present state
of the note is collected and sent to the
local machine so it's basically to check
that if the configuration changes that
we are about to make is already made so
it's not made we do not have the httpd
package installed on our node so this is
the first change that's made also if
it's not installed of course it's not
running that's the second change that's
made so it's put into the running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okie state this means that
the content is already present in the
client machine so I made it this way so
that you can only see the different
states that's present so over here we
have okay four so four things are all
fine the facts are gathered two things
are changed and one is already present
to change some it
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically and is very useful as you
can see the next step we need to just
check on a climber sheet if all the
changes that we desired are me so let's
move to our client
so this my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a webpage the best
way to do it is open your browser
and type in localhost
so there you go your Apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
thanks guys with that we reach the end
of this complete ansible tutorial I hope
you enjoyed this video do like and share
it thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simpler
[Music]